[Musique]
l'association les amis de théophraste
renaudot a été créé en 1970 je crois par
un érudit loudunais monsieur chartrand
et donc ils ont pris la gérance si l'on
peut dire
l'animation du musée en 1981 et depuis
donc cette association est bien elle les
a elle a en charge le musée ou sommes
dans la maison renaudot peut pas parler
mais son natal car nous nous sommes pas
sûrs qu'ils soient nés mais on est à peu
près sûr que il ya vécu dans cette
maison et donc c'est la maison musée de
renault taux qui a été achetée
qu'appartient la villa par la ville
et qui est donc animé par l'association
les amis de théophraste renaudot
vous avez différentes pièces est une
maison bourgeoise du 16e et avec le
salon la cuisine différentes pièces qui
sont restés un petit peu dans leur jus
le puits au milieu de la cuisine donc on
peut considérer qu' il y avait le
courant tu puisses y avait eu lieu à
proximité dans la cuisine même la cave
très profondes comme toutes les maisons
loudunaise bien on a extrait
on a extrait les pierres dans le sol
pour construire
le musée est installé ici avec des
machines et bien sûr une collection de
gazettes
puisque renaudot on considère que
renaudot est le premier journaliste
puisque les niveaux de l'inventeur de
journalisme puisque c'est lui qui a créé
la première gazette française le salon
où elle savons presque la collection
presque entière de gaz est ça qui a paru
donc 2631 jusqu'en 1915 et depuis donc
cette association est bien
elle est à elle a en charge le musée
mais aussi différentes animations donc
le prix renaudot des lycéens mais aussi
le prix renaudot des benjamins nous
organisons également un salon du livre
tous les ans au mois de novembre fixée
le mois renaudot le mois de novembre ce
qu'on a beaucoup d'animations il faut
dire que le prix renaudot des lycéens
eh bien il se passe un petit peu comme à
bari à paris cette restaurant drouant
eh bien à loudun c'est au restaurant
d'application du lycée professionnel
marc godrie donc on est tous autour de
la table ensuite pour célébrer la
proclamation